So now that i have my user
model in place, I will make
a use.pi file to handle the logic
of actually registering a new user.
I will structure this inpoint such that
a client can register a new user with
a post request to slash users.
The body of this request needs to be
a JSON object that has username and
password fields.
Let's take a look at the implementation
of this flask [INAUDIBLE].
The user name and
password arguments are obtained from
the JSON input coming from the request.
And then validated.
If the arguments are valid,
then a new user instance is created.
The user name is assigned to it.
And the password is hashed
using the hash_password method.
The user is then finally
written to the database.
The body of the response shows the user
representation as a JSON object,
with the status code of 201, so
let me run my application and
try registering a new user
with Postman like so.
We'll build this request in curl by
using the following command line text.
My server response that a new user
has successfully been created.
The views dot pi and model dot pi files
are available in the instructor notes.
It's also important to point
out that in a real application,
login should always be done
over a secure HTTP connection
If the login credentials are going to
travel through the networking,
clear text, they're are easily
visible to a potential hacker.
If you are interested in
learning more about HTTPS and
FLASK, check out some of the resources
provided in the instructor notes.